i
love taking my dog peppa to the dog park
or taking her for walks
she's greyhound and she goes really fast
i really love running and i really love
singing i think
all the time i love going to the gym on
a total gym bunny i'd go
at least five times a week i like taking
my daughter for a bike ride
crossword puzzles i really enjoy
readings i
read pretty much every day i would read
all day
i like to play the guitar i've been
doing it since i was 13 years old
so yep i make a racquet and annoy my
neighbors love it
i like text i like sandwich
and i like teeth i am going to go with
call
though i must admit i do text more than
i call um
cake and coffee i prefer a phone call
because i love talking to people
uh i'm gonna go coffee and cake texting
sandwich coffee
we mostly speak english but lately we've
been trying to speak a lot more of
torreira maori
just english triomari and english ah
in my whanau we speak english in te reo
maori and
i've got friends who speak chinese
estonian
catalan lots of different languages a
little bit of te reo and english
mostly english
literature and
oh japanese nihongo